le dossier du jour le premier était le
jour c'est être un enfant star alors
je sais je sais on va passer à ce
dossier justement de la semaine
puisqu'ils aucune idée de la gloire du
succès les banful en général c'est à 10
ans derrière il y a un album de ça
cartonne dans tous les sens parfois on
prend le bon chemin parfois le mauvais
parfois comme Lorie par exemple c'est le
bon et puis tout d'un coup ça s'arrête
parce que les gens vous ont aimé petit
veulent pas vous voir grandir parfois
comme je dis à 18 ans tu découvres qu'il
te reste même pas te quoi te payer un
studio parfois il y en a qui tombent
dans les extraits des extrêmes peuvent
braves je vais y arriver bref en tout
cas nous on a clémence et Priscillia qui
ont été deux énormes stars à partir de
l'âge de 11 ans regardez l'heure et cap
et ensuite on a la chance de les appeler
ils ont connu la célébrité alors qu'ils
étaient encore sur les bancs de l'école
ou qu'il suçaient leur pouce
et leur plus jeune âge ses enfants ont
été propulsés sur le devant de la scène
comme si leur destin était déjà tout
tracé
[Musique]
laisse faire remarquer dès l'âge de 15
ans grâce au Hit Machine c'est un
contestablement son tube je serai ta
meilleure amie qui va la faire exploser
auprès du grand public
[Musique]
trois mois après son apparition dans
graines de stars Alizée sortira quand
elle le titre moi Lolita écrit par
Mylène Farmer
et quand je donne ma langue au chat je
vois les autres un tube qui permettra
d'ailleurs à la jeune artiste en herbe
priscillabetti de se faire remarquer sur
le plateau drôle de petit champion
elle connaîtra peu de temps après un
franc succès avec son titre musique
[Musique]
malheureusement tous ne parviennent pas
à faire carrière dans le milieu comme
Jordy qui a seulement 4 ans se
produisait déjà sur scène avec sa
chanson dur dur d'être un bébé
[Musique]
ce soir retour sur ses enfants stars qui
ont marqué toute une génération avec son
autre plateau clémence et Priscilla
[Applaudissements]
on bouge déjà
je peux vous le dire
mais avant tellement de recevoir merci
beaucoup
mais je suis très heureux alors Clémence
vous c'est incroyable parce que quand
même vous avez fait juste un duo avec
Johnny Hallyday et non voilà on a les
images je crois
non pas peut-être voilà
je me souviens aussi quand elle était
petite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'exemplaire alors l'histoire est folle
parce qu'en fait c'est votre père qui
compose ça en fait pour vous et puis
Johnny il passe dans une dans une maison
de disque voilà on est en train
d'enregistrer et vous entend il entend
la chanson il se retourne il dit je veux
la chanson et je veux le vivre et donc
on a vous voir dit voilà bah Johnny va
chanter avec vous cette chanson c'est ça
venait de finir donc c'est sorti juste
après et c'était un single qui a fait un
million d'exemplaires c'est gigantesque
pour vous vous avez 12 ans
après vous vous allez revoir Johnny un
petit bon restant en contact ou pas du
tout cette couleur
les anniversaires les trucs quand on se
recroisait on était on avait toujours
une complicité un petit lien spécial
entre nous et quand il faisait des
tournées du coup après vous allez
tourner vous faisiez la chanson avec lui
non j'ai pas eu l'occasion de faire ça
mais mais on s'est revu à plusieurs
occasions il y a eu le disque d'or la
remise des disques d'or etc
mais vous avez 12 ans vous devenez une
star gigantesque en France vous allez
dire à l'école et tout et tout qu'est-ce
qui se passe à ce moment-là dans votre
vie mais c'était un peu chamboulé
j'avais des caméras qui viennent me
chercher à l'école à la sortie moi
j'étais toute gênée et tout mes copains
qui étaient là oh il y a des caméras
pour Clémence
ça m'ennuyait pas mais c'était un peu
spécial quoi et du coup tout le monde me
sollicitait à l'école
non non je l'ai pas vécu mal et à ce
moment-là vous pensez directement faire
une carrière ou pas
même avant ça c'est moi qui tenais mon
père quand il enregistrait cette chanson
à l'origine c'est pas du tout pour moi
et moi je lui dis j'avais 11 ans et je
lui ai dit papa je t'en supplie laisse
moi la chance d'enregistrer j'ai juste
envie de chanter et du coup un jour il
était en studio et à minuit je me suis
réveillé comme ça une fois que tout le
monde avait terminé je lui dis ok
maintenant c'est mon tour je me laisse
ma chance et est-ce que c'est le sens
cette chanson finalement c'est pas le le
le caillou dans la chaussure parce que
finalement ça arrive tellement vite vous
avez déclaré ça a été j'ai dû prendre du
recul j'ai dû partir à Londres je
commençais un peu à me perdre et tout ça
voilà finalement vous avez dû quitter la
France presque
à Londres j'ai rencontré mon mari donc
il était à Londres et je l'ai rejoint à
la barre j'ai eu besoin c'est vrai de
prendre un break mais le single avec
Johnny et entre le moment avec Johnny et
le moment que je suis parti allemand il
y a eu quelques années quand même fait
d'autres trucs entre-temps etc donc
c'était pas un caillou dans la chaussure
alors Jean-Michel
je disais tout à l'heure oui
c'est pareil pour dis-lui mais qu'est-ce
qu'il est bizarre
on n'a pas le droit de gagner de
l'argent
alors après je lui ai demandé du coup
c'était sur un compte spécial et vos
parents vous ont tout garder et donner à
votre majorité exactement comme genre
d'accord
aujourd'hui on est invité bien sûr il
veut plus parler du tout ensuite de ça
vous disparaissez un petit peu et puis
après on vous retrouve dans une comédie
musicale
avant ça il y a eu pour les étapes
j'ai eu sans défense la vie comme elle
quand j'adore il y a aussi le le
Concerto pour devoirs avec Jean-Baptiste
meunier c'est ça et ensuite j'ai tourné
un film en Chine où j'ai une petite
carrière en Chine alors vous avez quel
âge aujourd'hui aujourd'hui 33 ans 33
ans est-ce que malgré tout enfin il y a
pas toujours ce problème qui est que on
vous a connu pour un énorme single avec
Johnny on vous a aimé à 12 ans petite
mignonne et forcément on a peut-être les
fans n'ont pas envie d'avoir une fille
de 33 ans toujours mignonne mais est-ce
que c'est pas vous ramenez pas beaucoup
plus aujourd'hui parce que il y a eu ce
début pas du tout au contraire les gens
se souviennent de moi et c'est ça qui
est incroyable on me reconnaît toujours
dans la rue partout où je vais les gens
me disent en revanche les gens
m'appellent clémence et Johnny on
m'appelle pas Clémenceau
des gens dans la rue me disent c'est
Clément c'est Johnny donc c'est c'est
une anecdote sympathique mais quand on
vient de moi c'est pas compliqué de
couper le cordon quand même non et c'est
aussi pas mal d'avoir un cordon avec
Johnny
avec tout là dans la région
musique on l'a connu aussi pour plein
d'autres choses je la connais parce que
elle était dans une série que j'ai adoré
elle a fait d'autres titres elle a fait
des covers elle fait plein plein de
choses précisé
la première personne qui m'a vu sur un
plateau télé il est là
me brûle pas tout parce que j'ai quand
même un truc
effectivement vous faites tout ça mais
là où je pense quand même que j'ai
raison parce que je suis petit à mes
petites heures aussi
c'est que malgré tout que j'ai fait
couper le cordon c'est que vous
réussissez vous faites des singles des
singles malgré tout vous le sentez bien
vous vous reconnais pas plus que ça vous
tentez The Voice comme l'ont fait les
gars des boys born comme on fait
beaucoup de personnes à qui on a dit
finalement tu as fait un boy tu sais pas
chanter comme pour dire finalement je
vais retaper ma crédibilité je pars à
zéro vous faites The Voice oui on m'a
contacté pour le faire et je suis lancée
dans l'aventure en me disant j'adore
cette émission donc ça vous dérange pas
qu'on regarde l'extrait
que l'on
n'a pas su retenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ils m'ont dit on a c'est notre coup
de cœur quand tu l'as chanté celle-là
donc j'ai dit ok donc on vous a fait
parce que je vous promets en général ils
sont là j'adore cette chanson ils a pu
souvent quand on chante bien ça me dit
pas le contraire ça c'est c'est au-delà
de la médecine narcissique parce que
tout le monde vous regarde que vous êtes
chanteuse donc il y a un côté non vous
n'êtes pas c'est très dur à vivre non un
peu c'est sûr que c'est une déception
mais bon après je regrette pas de
l'avoir fait pour autant c'était une
bonne expérience ah ouais moi je me
souviens plus il vous a reconnu après je
me souviens plus du tout ce qui s'est
passé après quand tu sortes
alors aujourd'hui vous sortez un album
quand même effectivement voilà je suis
ici ah j'adore voilà je préfère
c'est magnifique
l'amour se raconte en musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme ça Michel Polnareff toi de sortir
un cover il refait toutes ses chansons
juste piano voir la star d'ailleurs et
c'est très très beau c'est une super
idée merci
c'est une très très bonne idée il y a un
clip et tout ça donc pas de regret de
Johnny vous parlez à Laetitia de temps
en temps
pas beaucoup non à personne de la
famille non non
[Rires]
est-ce que je peux demander quelque
chose qu'est-ce que votre avis parce
qu'il y a eu un moment il y a eu Vanessa
Paradis il y a eu Elsa il y a eu Lorie
il y a eu Alizée qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'une gamine comme vous de 12 ans qui
est si jolie qu'est-ce qui fait que le
truc a moins pris qu'est-ce qui fait que
ça prend ou ça prend pas pour des
enfants comme ça
de prendre un peu de distance en ayant
commencé si jeune comme ça après on a
besoin enfin moi personnellement j'ai eu
besoin de grandir et de faire les choses
à dos que j'avais pas fait à l'époque où
je faisais des concerts et des
enregistrements et des trucs j'ai eu
besoin de prendre un peu de temps pour
me retrouver artistiquement et ça
pourrait
être avec le notoriété si mais je suis
quelqu'un un peu réservé c'est vrai et
puis en ayant commencé très jeune et
étant beaucoup orienté par les gens
autour de moi j'avais besoin vraiment
savoir qui j'étais toute seule et donc
comment ça à écrire à composer et puis
j'étais à Londres mais j'ai jamais cessé
de te dire
il y a aussi le talent mais aussi les
rencontres qu'on a sur notre chemin qui
fait que ça fait durer une carrière on
peut être très talentueux mais si on n'a
pas les bonnes personnes autour de nous
et bah parfois on n'arrive pas à avancer
moi j'ai la chance d'avoir Mathieu
ça serait plus compliqué pour moi aussi
pour un chanteur pour un animateur c'est
aussi savoir s'entourer et parfois c'est
pas évident c'est vrai et dépensez tout
dans les boîtes de nuit un jour j'y mets
Internet les conneries tu vas faire
n'importe quoi dans n'importe quel
agence immobilière et tu achètes un
appart un studio ce que tu veux il est
allé il a acheté un truc et au moins
comme ça voilà ça c'est à toi parce que
il en faisait des conneries le petit
héros là là qu'est-ce qu'il y a alors
vous préciser à évidemment connu pour
plein plein de tubes mais vous avez été
révélé au tout début des années 2000 par
un très grand producteur animateur qui
vous a appelé dans une émission qui
s'appelle drôle de petit champion sur
TF1 vous n'aviez que 12 ans l'animateur
était ici et évidemment on a les images
père américaine reçoit enfin Prescillia
tu es si gentille
ça fait plaisir tu es trop mignonne sur
la photo regardez tous comme elle est
jolie
c'est pour toi tu es contente
je vais te chanter une petite chanson
[Musique]
tu es adorable
je peux te le dire
rapidement on faisait une émission qui
s'appelle drôle de petit champion avec
un talent de chaux
ouais pas vraiment c'était plein de
talent différent un peu importe et il y
avait mon associé de Nini moi à l'époque
il faut quand même que je salue et
Patrick Debord qui travaille avec nous à
l'époque donc c'est important de le
saluer qu'on dit souvent bataille
fontaine aux découvertes Priscilla Denis
limon et Patrick Debord ont découvert
chez nous pressilia et puis on a eu nous
en tant qu'animateur précis face à nous
ce petit bout de quelques semaines en
semaine quand ça marche
je venais pour voir un peu les l'envers
du décor d'une émission j'ai adoré
regarder cette émission avec mes parents
quand elle passait et je vous laisse
tout simplement les chanter quoi juste
derrière qu'est-ce qui se passe derrière
ce qui se passe c'est que je sors du
plateau et là donc il y a Patrick Debord
qui prend ma mère en loge et qui lui
parle lui dit écoutez voilà moi je fais
beaucoup de télé producteurs de télé
puis j'aimerais bien redevenir redevenir
de la musique et je serais très
intéressé par votre fille par là pour la
produire un dressing etc et c'est parti
tout simplement comme ça ça part et là
il y a album
on voit que tu veux tu veux y arriver
ici ou sur ce plateau que j'ai pas fait
de plateau télé oui je suis très
contente d'être avec vous ce soir
ils sont là pour toi ou alors on est au
Jacky show Dorothée c'est comme vous
voulez ils sont là pour toi s'il te
plaît
[Rires]
c'est plus fort que moi
à chaque fois je mens les doigts tout le
monde en fait trop pas assez voilà
un drôle de choix
sans en avoir l'air mais c'est un repère
j'avoue je les perds
tout aussi sincère l'envie de plaire et
son contraire tout le monde laisse moi
déteste moi
aime-moi
regarde-moi
terre ce mois
déteste moi
mais surtout regarde-moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
direction ce plateau les artistes en
général chanter tu sais il faut faire
les réserves
merci je suis désolé
[Rires]
alors oui et
donc
comme ça très bien hop toi ça part ça
décolle pour toi zéro regret bam les
albums sortent tu pars même aux
États-Unis mais j'ai rencontré Britney
ouais
bien sûr c'est pour une émission qui
s'appelait les petits anges à l'époque
et je leur mettais un petit ange de le
cheval de la chanteuse de l'année
quelque chose comme ça ouais mais à ce
moment-là pareil toi c'est un succès
gigantesque tu as quel âge que tu sors
deux albums très proches ouais ouais ben
j'ai 12-13 ans 12-13 ans ça te tourne à
la tête tu viens de quelle famille
modeste modeste comment ils vivent tout
ça
elle pleure beaucoup
de parents qui poussent vachement leur
gosse faut le dire moi j'ai rencontré
des parents pleins de fois on les a reçu
plein de fois on avait fait des
surprises avec tes parents je sais pas
si dommage qu'on est pas la vidéo mais
peu importe en fait c'est des gens qui
ne poussez pas pris sous ils étaient
poussés par prison j'adore la prise sous
cette année
dans la famille
elles sont indépendantes en pharmacie
mais ma grande sœur aînée qui est
chanteuse professionnelle donc elles
sont déjà parties elles et quand on vous
écoute tout est génial il y a bien un
moment compliqué il y avait ça a été
compliqué pourquoi ça a été compliqué
parce que je leur ai pris leur maman
quelque part
avec moi au quotidien j'étais mineur etc
donc il fallait qu'elle m'accompagne
parce qu'on était suivi quand même par
la baisse du spectacle et à l'école et
l'école je suis vain cursus normal
j'allais je montais le mercredi
ça a pas été évident ou les petits
étaient jaloux forcément l'argent pardon
mais pareil les paramètres de côté tu
récupères
consignation
récupère tout quand tu es majeur
exactement et aux impôts tu es content
bonne partie aux impôts en France
voilà
[Rires]
idem aujourd'hui mais je pose la
question mais c'est vrai tu es Priscilla
rien que le prénom on fait enfant tu es
Priscilla la gamine qu'on a adoré à 12
ans et qui chantait tout est-ce que les
gens attendent autre chose de toi est-ce
que tu penses que tu pourras leur donner
autre chose alors je pense que personne
n'attend rien de moi moi non non
vraiment j'ai juste envie moi de j'ai
toujours ma communauté de fans qui sont
là ils sont propres autant présents j'ai
passé une de nombreuses années à ne rien
pouvoir leur proposer ni single ni petit
échantillon de quoi que ce soit et ils
ont toujours été là moi ce que je fais
aujourd'hui c'est que je vis et je
continue à en faire mon métier plus dans
l'ombre que sur la plateaux télé mais
quelque part voilà je suis toujours là
j'ai une question à l'une et l'autre si
vous aviez une fille de 8-10 ans qui me
fait des concours de The Voice Kid et
des machins instant c'est là-dedans vous
voulez pousser
si c'est ce qu'elle a envie de faire je
l'accompagnerai du mieux que je peux
dire non
c'est le thème de l'émission de Philippe
Thuillier ce soir sur France 3 toutes
les chansons de notre enfance et on y
voit Priscilla
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un truc comme ça n'hésitez pas à nous on
a pas besoin d'oreilles
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter le
mieux des conseils est-ce que tu faisais
encore beaucoup de concerts ou pas ben
oui quand même pas mal de petites
annonces à faire je fais partie d'un
collectif qui s'appelle les comédies
musicales le grand show et ça ça vient
de tomber c'est une grosse exclu on fait
le dôme de Paris le 15 mars 2024 je
viens de l'apprendre [ __ ] pourquoi
c'est pas beaucoup
c'est pas moi qui l'anime
ça vient de l'intérieur sur mon
téléphone
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]